حسب تصريحات وكاله او اداره الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه فان عدد المباني التي
انهارت جراء هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه
ظهر اليوم بلغ تسعه وعشرين مبنى جاري الان
او فرق الانقاذ والاغاثه تعمل على رفع
الانقاد بخمس مباني يعتقد ان ان يوجد
تحتها
عالقين لحد الان مقتل تم تسجيل مقتل شخص
واصابه تسعه وستين اخرين بجروح فيما تم
ايضا انقاذ شخصين من تحت الانقاض شاهدنا
قبل لحظات فيديوهات لاخراجهم بان تحت
الانقاذ هناك ايضا تم تسجيل 25 بلاغا من
المواطنين ولذلك تحركت فرق الانقاذ
والاغاثه التابعه لمنظمه افاد اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه هذا الزلزال الجديد قال عنه مدير
اداره افاد بانه
امر طبيعي يريد ان يهدئ نوعا ما المواطنين
ودعاهم للاستعداد لما هو ات من هزات وصفها
بانها ستكون قويه نوعا ما ستتجاوز الخمس
درجات على سلم ريختر وكانت هناك تحذيرات
للمواطنين بالابتعاد عن المباني تحسبا لاي
طارئ المكان الذي اتواجد فيه الان لا يبعد
عن الحدود السوريه التركيه الا باقل من
كيلومتر او كيلو مترين هناك حاله طوارئ
ايضا يعني في هذه البلده هناك اعمال جاريه
لتسويه ارضيه واسعه سيتم وضع فوقها مبالغ
جاهزه وشاليهات لاواء الاف المتضررين في
هذه البلده التي فقدت لوحدها حوالي سته
الاف قتيل اثراء الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه
في السادس من فبراير الماضي وايضا هناك
الالاف ممن اصبحوا بدون ماوى تجولنا في
هذه البلده ولم يعد هناك اي شخص في
المباني المتصدعه وهناك مخاوف من العوده
اليها